We're taking calls, a lot of interest from
folks calling in today.
Let's go at (617) 830-4750
D to our call or maybe a local call or from
the seven seven four area code seven seven
four.
Are you there?
Yes, I am.
Hi David.
Hi.
How are you?
I'm good.
I'm from math, but in Providence now.
So, uh, what I wonder is maybe it's just cause
we're in Southern new England, but everywhere
I look I see Bernie supporters, yet somehow
Biden is still leading in the primaries.
Right?
Do you think that maybe there is less of us
and we're just shouting louder?
Yeah.
So, I mean, what you have to understand about
mass, I can speak about Massachusetts.
Massachusetts has a huge contingent of sort
of what we would call establishment Democrats.
They're like more Kennedy types rather than
Bernie types, if that makes sense.
And they don't put signs out, but they do
vote and they support people like Joe Biden.
Um, so I definitely think that when you, you
know, that's, that's the reason why, even
though it feels like you drive around and
see Bernie signs in the polls, uh, Joe Biden
may still be doing well in Massachusetts,
although I'll be honest, I haven't looked
at Massachusetts polling lately, so I'm just
taking your word for it.
But yeah, this is th there's a long history
in Massachusetts of center left democratic
support and less sort of like further left
democratic support.
Okay.
And am I the only one that's a little scared
that maybe if Bernie doesn't get the nomination
there's going to be kind of a revolt with
the young viewers like there was with that
because they didn't get the exact turnout
they wanted that they're just not really going
to turn up
because they don't get the exact outcome they
want.
Yeah.
I've talked about this and I, this is a concern
of mine and I'm trying not to fuel it by you
know, becoming adversarial with people.
I've just been trying to approach it from
a more positive perspective, which is we should
all understand that during the primary we
advocate for and we support the candidate
that we believe most closely aligns with our
views and then not all of those, not everybody's
going to get the candidate they want.
In November of 2020 we have to turn out and
make sure we remove Donald Trump.
I'm trying to be more positive rather than
to address any specific groups that I think
might stay home or vote Trump in some kind
of protest.
I hope it doesn't happen because it could
ruin the November of 2020 election.
Exactly.
And I think if maybe Bernie did get the ticket,
there'd be record turnout like what there
was for Obama.
It's possible.
It's certainly, I think that, uh, Donald Trump
more than anything else may catalyze record
turnout.
And then if you combine that with a particularly
charismatic or appealing candidate, you could
end up with record turnout for multiple reasons.
For sure.
Yeah.
That orange idiot, it needs to go
right.
Yes.
The Tangerine T, what was the, I read the,
the Tangerine tumor as someone referred to
him.
Um, okay.
Thank you so much for the call.
Really great to hear from you.
Yup.
Thank you.
Let's go next to, where do we want to go next?
Why not the five seven zero area code?
Let's talk to our caller from five seven zero.
Uh, what's your name?
Where are you calling from?
Hi David.
My name is Josh cane.
I'm from Pennsylvania.
Hey Josh.
What's up?
Uh, I'm uh, Hey.
I'm a big fan of your show, David, because,
uh, you're progressive, but I feel that you
take things from a positive perspective and
when you talk about issues, I feel that you
don't read from an ideological rule book.
So thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you for all of your excellent analysis.
But, uh, I just have a simple question.
I'm sorry if it's been asked before, but I
wanted to know, um, if you had to vote right
now in the democratic primary, uh, who would
you vote for?
Bernie or Warren?
I've said I'm a Bernie Warren guy.
Okay, great.
Awesome.
Um, thank you, David.
All right.
Thank you so much.
I appreciate the call.